beth is you know the scientists are
doing their job the regulators have now
done their job on this particular
vaccine
and it is going to be down to the
government to get this vaccine out
to the people who so badly need it
yes mark and there's lots of questions
around this particular vaccine the fisa
vaccine
is the one that requires being stored at
minus 70 degrees celsius and that does
make it harder to distribute for all the
obvious
reasons the oxford vaccine uh that is
still
a weight in regulatory approval you can
store that in a fridge
so it's much less complicated much
easier
to distribute so questions around care
homes can the government get it into
care homes the welsh government's saying
it's logistically
too difficult now that's interesting
because if i look at the vaccine
priority groups which was published
today by the department of health
and social care the priority group the
number one group is residents in care
homes
um and then carers and then it goes down
for the next uh
group it's those over 80 years old
and frontline health and social care
workers
working down the list then number three
is the 75 years of age and over and it
goes
down and down but the priorities
residents and caregiving the question is
can the government realistically get it
out to care homes
we'll be hearing at the press conference
mark from the deputy
chief medical officer jonathan von tam
and then sir simon stevens the chief
executive
of nhs england now uh you'll not see him
often at press because i think this
might just be the third
one he's done don't hold me to that but
he very rarely
appears so maybe he'll have a message
about vaccinations
and about the nhs over the winter months
because while the vaccine nation is
coming on stream
of course the prime minister of prime
minister's questions today warned
too that this is not the panacea
that we've still got a difficult few
weeks and months to get through
as we go through that winter period
traditionally very very difficult
anyway for the nhs let alone
when it's also fighting a pandemic i
should just
um point out it is just uh after five
o'clock this is the newshour
and uh i'm mark austin talking to beth
rigby our political editor about the
news conference that we're told is about
to begin
at downing street and beth on that point
you were making
you know this is about tone isn't it now
because
he doesn't want people to relax that was
the point he was making last night
particularly um over christmas so
there's a
there's a there's a challenge to get the
tone right here isn't there
yeah absolutely because it is brilliant
news
that we are getting vaccines on stream
and it really will once
these vaccines are properly fully rolled
out uh be our passport back to
a more normal life and perhaps end in
social distancing
and i don't know even going to a party
or going dancing i mean all the things
for
months and none of us have been able to
do but
it's not yet we still have the tiered
system coming in today
very limited social interactions beyond
our households
for the vast majority of people in tiers
and tiers iii and those tiers will run
they will be reviewed but the prime
minister being very clear
this week that they will expire not
until february the third and could
they run into april uh which was when he
gave the end point wasn't it uh when he
announced his
new lockdown and tearing system uh that
was the end point that we're all aiming
for well that is a few months
away so yes a vaccine is coming on
stream but does it really change
the government's strategy going into the
winter months particularly when you look
at the
cost analysis that the government put
out before the vote uh this week about
the reasons why they were
uh bringing the tier system in and and
the economic and societal costs
of doing this tier system it was very
clear
from that document that the thing that
the government could measure was the
pressure on the nhs they said should the
virus
should we do nothing and the virus runs
on it would be intolerable because the
nhs would be
unable to cope with patients that was
the clear message
from the government but of course the
economic costs well they said it's not
possible to measure but that of course
is what many many mps are very very
unhappy and concerned about
and why there was such a big rebellion
against the prime minister last night
and also messaging about the safety of
the vaccine
of course because there are people who
are hesitant because it is a
a new vaccine they want to be reassured
i see the suggestion that
boris johnson might have a to have the
jab live on television
well i he was uh his spokesperson was
asked about that
at our daily lobby briefing where
westminster journalists
ask uh down the street various questions
and that was asked
and maybe someone will ask that at the
press conference as well will you have
it live
on air but you're right in terms of uh
concerns around this vaccine a poll just
out from yougov
says one in five britons are concerned
about uh the vaccine or they're not that
confident about the vaccine rather said
yeah not confident in the vaccine i mean
you can understand why
vaccines like this normally take a
decade to develop we've done it in 10
months it's a scientific triumph no
doubt
but the corollary of that the fallout of
that is some people
might feel a bit anxious about this
vaccine
and what does the government need to do
to convince people the prime minister
clear
in the commons today that he will not be
making it mandatory for people to have
this vaccine
but there is a question how do you
persuade healthy people
under the age of 65 to take a vaccine to
stop the transmission
of a disease when they're perfectly
healthy i mean there is a question
in all of this and the government's
position seems to be that they hope
that people will take the vaccine but
what if they don't what is the
knock-on effect for public health policy
and i think
those are questions in the coming weeks
we will probably ask
and hopefully get answered by the
government yeah okay
particularly with all this
misinformation and wacky theories on
social media but i can see the prime
minister
uh about to emerge so let's uh
listen to the prime minister beth rigby
thanks very much indeed afternoon and
welcome to the latest number ten
press conference i'm very pleased to be
joined by uh jonathan van tambeep deputy
chief
medical officer and simon stephens chief
executive of nhs
england it is almost a year since
humanity has been tormented by
covid across the world economic output
has plummeted
and a million and a half people have
died all the time we've been waiting
and hoping for the day when the
searchlights of science
would pick out our invisible enemy and
give us
the power to stop that enemy from
making us ill and now the scientists
have done it and they've used the virus
itself to perform a kind of biological
jujitsu
to turn the virus on itself in the form
of
of a vaccine in a an idea that i think
was pioneered in this country
by edward jenner in 1796
and today we can announce that the
government has accepted the
recommendation from the independent
uh medicines and healthcare products
regulatory agency
to approve the fisa biontech
vaccine for distribution across the
united kingdom
after months of clinical trials
involving thousands of people
to ensure that the vaccine meets the
strictest
internationally recognized standards of
safety quality
and effectiveness thanks to the
fantastic work of
kate bingham and the vaccines task force
we've purchased
more than 350 million doses of seven
different vaccine candidates and the uk
was the first country in the world to
pre-order supplies
of this pfizer vaccine securing 40
million doses through our winter plan
the nhs has been preparing for the
biggest program
of mass vaccination in the history of
the uk and that's going to begin
next week and in line with the advice of
the independent
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
the first phase will include care home
residents
health and care staff the elderly and
those who are
clinically extremely vulnerable but
there are immense
logistical challenges the virus has got
to be stored
at minus 70 degrees each person needs
two injections
three weeks apart so it will inevitably
take
some months before all the most
vulnerable are protected
long cold months so it's all the more
vital that as we celebrate this
scientific achievement we're not
carried away with over optimism
or fall into the naive belief
that the struggle is over it's not we've
got to stick to
our winter plan a comprehensive program
to suppress the virus
protect the nhs and the vulnerable keep
education
and the economy going and use treatments
testing
and vaccines to enable us to return to
much closer to normal by the spring
today in england we've ended national
restrictions
opening up significant parts of the
economy in doing so
but also replacing them with tough tears
to keep
this virus down and i know that those
tears will mean continued
uh hardship for for many and it's gonna
continue to be
tough for some sectors but until the
vaccine
is deployed our plan does rely
on all of us continuing to make
sacrifices to protect
those we love so please please continue
to follow
the rules where you live remember hands
face
space and if you live in a tier
3 area where community
testing will be made available please
take part in that community testing
together these steps are for now
the surest way to protect yourselves and
those you love and by reducing the
transmission of the virus
help de-escalate your area
to a lower level of restrictions as
as vaccines and testing as i say take an
ever larger share
of the burden as we do all this
we're no longer resting on the mere hope
that we can return
to normal uh next year
in the spring but rather the sure and
certain knowledge
that we will succeed and together
reclaim our lives and all the things
about our lives that we love so i want
to thank the scientists
and all those around the world who've
taken part uh in the trials
and got us to this stage and i want to
hand over now to simon stevens of the
nhs
uh thank you and uh good afternoon
obviously as the prime minister
says today is a news uh
bringing great optimism uh we have a
vaccine that has been independently
shown to be
both safe and effective but i suspect
that what people
want are practical answers to three
questions
who will be first in line when will the
vaccines be available
and how will we get it to you from the
nhs
so taking those three questions in turn
first of all
in terms of who will be first in line as
the prime minister says
the independent medical experts the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
have clearly recommended that the nhs
should make sure
that the first people to be offered the
vaccine are those at
highest risk together with the people
who look after them
in practice what that means is starting
with the
over 80s who are at much higher risk of
severe outcomes from coronavirus as well
as people in care homes
together with some of the frontline
health and social care staff who are
looking after them
and then as more vaccine becomes
available we will be
in the new year extending that to many
more people
across the country in line with the jcvi
recommendations
so that in turn helps answer the
question when in that
although we are the first health service
in the world to be able to get
vaccinating
supplies from the manufacturer are
phased
so the initial tranche in december is
going to enable us to get started
but the bulk of this vaccination program
either through this vaccine
or hopefully others as well that will
join it will take place
in the period january through to march
or april for the
at-risk population
the majority of the early vaccinations
will as i say be for the over 80s and
for
care home residents and since you need
two jabs with an initial injection and
then a booster
typically around 21 days apart that
means that
we've got to reserve the second dose for
the people who are getting the first
dose in december
to make sure that that second dose is
available for them
and it also means that the people who
are getting the first dose in december
will not have the full protection from
the vaccine
until they get the second dose in
january which
emphasizes the point that we need to
continue to be extremely careful
during december and into january and
then as the vaccination expands to the
wider population
so that's who and that's when in terms
of how
the vaccine that has been approved for
the nhs to deploy
today the fisa beyond tech vaccine has
been
independently shown to be medically safe
but it is
logistically complicated we have to move
it around the country
in a carefully controlled way initially
at minus 70 degrees centigrade or
thereabouts
and then there are a limited number of
further movements that we are
allowed by the regulator to make it also
comes in packs of 975 people's doses
so you can't at this point just
distribute it to
every individual gp surgery or pharmacy
as we normally would for many of the
other vaccines available
on the nhs so
the phasing of delivery the way we will
do it
is that next week around 50 hospital
hubs
across england will start offering the
vaccine
to the over 80s and to care home
staff and others identified by the jcvi
typically they may be people who were
already down to come into hospital next
week for an outpatient appointment
so if you're going to be one of those
people next week or in the
weeks that follow the hospital will get
in touch with you
you don't need to do anything about it
yourself that will then be followed
in the subsequent weeks with gp
practices coming together
in each area to operate local
vaccination centers
and that will grow to over a thousand
places
right across england where gps will be
in touch with their at-risk patients
inviting people to come forward for
vaccination
we've had an excellent response from gps
across the nhs
wanting to participate in this program
and as the extra vaccine comes available
we'll be able to turn on more of those
gp led
clinics and then if the
mhra the independent regulator as we
expect they will
give approval for a safe way of
splitting these packs of 975 doses
then the good news is that we will be
able to start
distributing those two care homes
and then as even more vaccine becomes
available
finally we will be able to switch on
large vaccination centers across the
country
and indeed invite local community
pharmacists
probably at the beginning of january to
begin to offer vaccination
as well so in a nutshell
this is going to be a phased program we
the nhs
your gp or your hospital the nhs will
contact you
if you are ready to be offered the
vaccination
and today of course is a day of great
optimism but for all the reasons i've
said i think it needs to be tempered
with
realism around phasing the nhs has got a
fantastic track record
around vaccine delivery but this is the
first time in the world
that these particularly complicated
logistics are being put into practice
and finally i should of course conclude
i think with a big thank you to
not only the scientists and the
researchers who
have managed to produce this vaccine but
to all of my fellow staff across the
health service
the nurses and doctors and the
therapists and the paramedics
who are all going to now mobilize for
what is the biggest vaccination campaign
in our history thank you thanks very
much simon uh
john anything to add thanks prime
minister
yes i'd like to add a few um science
reflections if i may
and and begin with the fact to tell you
quite openly and i don't mind telling
you
um i'm not saying it for effect the
office will tell you it's true
that i was quite emotional this morning
when i heard
june reign seminar mohammed and wei shen
lim
lay out how they got very meticulously
to their conclusions about the fisa
vaccine
and what a momentous you know journey
and international
effort it has been um discovery
by two scientists who originally
lived in turkey development by a german
biotech company
involvement of a massive u.s
pharmaceutical giant
and then involvement of our own uk mhra
to bring home the goods in terms of the
uk what a fantastic
journey and um i i gave you the train
analogy many weeks ago now
the train has now slowed down safely it
has now stopped in the station
and the doors have opened that was the
authorization
by the mhra what we need now is for
people to get on that train
and travel safely to their destinations
those destinations are all over the uk
this train is going to stop several
times on the way
it's going to have to reach all parts of
the uk
there will be trains that come behind it
and that is all going to take time
so everyone needs to be delighted with
the news today
but equally patient and realistic
about how this rolls out over the next
few months
and now some serious science points
number one we have one authorized
vaccine
but we need more we're very hopeful we
will get some more
but it is still possible that some of
the ones in development
will fall by the wayside and you have to
be prepared for that
we then need assured supply and that is
a big
and difficult ask for manufacturers and
it won't all come at once
and it may stop and start a bit at times
we just have to manage that as best we
can
as it happens number three
we need people to take it this vaccine
isn't going to help you if you don't
take it
and you will need two doses of this
vaccine and most of the others
to have full protection
watching others take it and hoping that
this will then protect
you isn't going to work necessarily
we don't know if this vaccine will
prevent transmission
or any of them we have to wait for the
science to tell us
if it will prevent transmission though
we are
very hopeful on that point we also have
to be patient
to see the real live effects on
transmission
and hospitalizations and deaths and
until we see that as scientists
we can't then scope what the likely
impact is going to be
on bringing this pandemic to an early
end
and rollout won't be instant already on
the jcvi
phase one list we have around about
30 million people who are going to be
targeted at some point
and even if you gave me 60 million
vaccines here in this corner now
in a freezer of course but if you gave
me the 60 million
um i couldn't you know no no system in
the world
could distribute those really really
quickly in a matter of a few days
so we have to be realistic about how
long this is going to take it's going to
take months not weeks
and for now the other measures
the tear measures the social distancing
have to stay in place if we relax too
soon
if we just kind of go oh the vaccine's
here let's abandon caution
all you're going to do is create a tidal
wave of infections
and this vaccine has then got to work in
a headwind
to get back ahead of the game and that
will make it harder
and then the final point is look you
know everyone wants
social distancing to come to an end
we're fed up with it
nobody wants lockdowns and to see the
damage they do
but if you want that dream to come true
as quickly as it can come true
then you have to take the vaccine when
it's offered to you
low uptake will almost certainly make
restrictions last
longer and finally please
stick to the guidance until we say it is
safe to stop
thank you prime minister thanks very
much sean jones let's go to questions
from the public
first dylan from thousands of year 13
students like myself across the country
have been held in suspense
over the last few months over at a
levels
when does the government intend to
provide certainty as to what is being
planned for next
summer uh right dylan thank you very
much and
uh first of all i want to thank
everybody who's
been in school and the efforts that
schools teachers pupils have gone to to
keep our schools going that's been one
of the prime objectives of
uh the way we fought the pandemic here
in uh in this country to to make sure
kids are
are in school uh dylan uh we're gonna be
sending out some more tomorrow
about uh about exams but let me just say
that we want
uh exams to to go ahead we think they're
very
uh very important but we'll also be
setting out some ways which we're gonna
help uh uh pupils to to do them
uh next summer given the exceptional
circumstances that
the country finds itself in and given
that uh you know so many
uh pupils have had uh their education
disrupted
by the pandemic so we'll be sending out
a lot more about that
uh tomorrow let's go to catherine
uh from from queneboro
and i'm sorry catherine asks which
hospitality tear restrictions
remain in place over the christmas
relaxation
will families be able to socialize in
pubs and restaurants
or just in their in their houses and
i'm i'm sorry to say um uh catherine
that we've got to stick with the
uh the the guidance that we've uh
we've set out the tiering system
throughout the the christmas period
uh as simon was was was just saying and
jonathan
as well uh it would be a really fatal
mistake now
uh to uh to respond to this good news
uh by uh letting the virus uh you know
uh run riot again uh letting it get out
of uh control by
too much uh uh transmission over
over christmas and so that's why we've
got to stick uh very tightly to the
tearing
that we've uh we've set out um let's go
to questions from them from the media
fergus walsh bbc
prime minister now we have a vaccine how
important is this moment uh
well fergus this is a a huge moment and
as as jvt was jonathan van tan was just
saying it's
also a very moving thing and i'm really
lost in admiration for
for science uh and the ability of
scientists to
to solve human problems in the way that
uh they can and this is not easy i mean
don't bear in mind we've got a we've got
a
a vaccine now for for covid that really
really works there's no question that it
uh that it works but we haven't got a
vaccine for
uh for for sars or for for mers
for for hiv you know there's a huge
huge fantastic effort has gone into this
and um when you consider the damage that
as i was saying earlier the damage that
this virus has done to
uh human life across the uh the planet
the economic damage the social damage to
say nothing of the
the cost in in life and and suffering it
is a fantastic moment
but you know to repeat the key message
the worst thing now
would be to think that this is the the
moment when we can
relax our guard and uh think that it's
game over in the fight against kobe this
is not
uh this is not the end uh we have to
fight on and we have to
continue with the uh the tough measures
that we've
uh that we've we've announced today
thanks very much uh fergus let's go to
uh to emily morgan
of itv hello thank you a question uh to
you prime minister
uh your scientists have said that care
home residents should be
the first people to get this uh vaccine
are you confirming then
that they won't be and if uh
not aren't you failing to protect our
most vulnerable and if i may
a question to you simon stevens what are
you doing right now to address this
logistical challenge to get the vaccine
to care homes sooner rather than later
well i i think i'll i'll ask simon
to to correct me if i've got this wrong
but you're quite right the
the issue is we of course we want to get
it uh into care homes to protect the
the most vulnerable as fast as we uh
possibly
can the the joint committee on
vaccination and
immunization has rightly said that care
home residents
must be a priority uh the the difficulty
is in uh distributing the uh the cases
to
uh care homes each case has 975
uh vaccines in it and obviously
you want to avoid wastage and the the
difficulty is that the mhra has not yet
uh
authorized the the people who would be
uh transporting
uh the vaccine to the to the care homes
to be able to effect the division
uh themselves i know it sounds uh
complicated
uh emily that's because th this this
vaccine
and and and jv team also jonathan may
want to come back on this
this vaccine is uh it's
it's it needs to be kept uh deep frozen
as you know minus
uh 75. uh there is a risk that if it is
allowed to to degenerate by being
improperly handled it simply
won't work so the rules around the
the transport of this vaccine are
extremely important and
to get to your point about um speeding
this up and making sure we get it into
care homes
uh as soon as possible we're expecting
to hear
more soon from the mhra about how that
can happen but
i think it'd be fair to say that there
are we certainly want to be
uh putting it into uh the the groups
that
uh simon uh talked about just now care
home residents
uh care workers uh nhs and above all
above all those above 80 uh who
are the most vulnerable our objective
must be
to use the vaccine stocks that we have
to protect those who are most likely uh
not just to fall ill but to succumb uh
to the disease that's the
that's the what what the jcvi has
decided i think
uh quite rightly but uh jonathan and
simon
if i may come in prime minister and say
emily i think
your um remarks about failure
are extremely unfair when one considers
that a new virus emerged less than 12
months ago
and we already have our first vaccine
and professor stevens has been very
clear
that as soon as it is legally and
technically possible to get the vaccine
into care homes
we will do so but you know that this is
a complex
product with a very fragile cold chain
it's not a yogurt that can be taken out
of the fridge
and put back in multiple times it's
really tricky to handle
and so i think you know we'll get there
as fast as we can
is the answer and we are trying
extremely hard
sorry well no i think you both said it
absolutely accurately i mean we are
raring to go in the nhs we want to be
able to vaccinate people in care homes
for covet just as we vaccinate
care home residents for many other
things including winter flu
just as soon as we have the regulatory
sign off that we can
do that we can get the jabs to the care
homes so the gps and the nurses can then
arrive and give those care home
residents that cover vaccination we will
do that and we
at this point with a fair wind fully
expect that that will be in the
first tranche of uh priorities for
vaccination
uh during uh this month thanks very much
thanks emily let's go to beth rugby's go
news
thank you prime minister we've got two
big events today
celebrations about the vaccine but also
unhappiness
about the tier system you've told mps
that current restrictions will expire
on february the 3rd but given that you
also said in your covered winter plan
that january and february are
traditionally the hardest months for the
nhs the depths of winter
when our hospital wards are under the
greatest pressure
should we all still prepare for
restrictions to run
through to april and if i may to
professor van tan
one in five britons have said in a just
released yougov poll they're not
confident
about this vaccine how worried are you
that people
won't take it and given that you just
said we don't know if it reduces
transmission what percentage of the
population would need to take
it uh for it to be effective in us for
to be able to lift
restrictions thank you beth well first
of all just on the
on the tearing and yes of course you
know i totally
accept that uh that they're tough the
these tears are obviously
a huge amount of the economy is is
opened up but the
the restrictions uh do remain tough
particularly
in tier three on hospitality and we
deeply deeply
regret that we're doing everything we
can to to help but
you know the the the way forward is not
just
the steady rollout of the vaccine that
we've uh and several vaccines we hope
that we've been describing over the next
few weeks and months
but also uh uh
observation of the the tiering plus
community
testing as as we have in as they have in
liverpool with great success 284
thousand people in liverpool
uh took part in in community mass
testing and
so local leaders uh mps everyone can get
together
to do those uh community tests and drive
the uh and isolate the positives uh and
uh help the negatives uh to do things
differently and that way drive the the
incidents down and and get the virus
under keep the virus under control and
come down the tears
uh we hope we hope uh before uh easter
as well so that's the the tool that we
see uh working in addition uh to the
vaccine
so beth thanks for the questions um
on a vaccine that reduces transmission
that is always the final big win if you
can get a vaccine that does that
because we can't be sure of that yet and
we'll have to wait and see if that
is the case with this vaccine and others
to follow i'm
quite optimistic but far from certain
um and because we can't say to what
extent the percentage of transmission
that is taken out by the vaccine because
it's not binary it's not kind of
it either does or it doesn't it's a
percentage that it will take out
until we know that and the scientists
can model that we won't be able to say
the kind of total
population vaccine uptake the magic
number you're after and
understand why you're after it but we
can't give it to you yet
but i don't want to take away from the
the fact that the
not immediate but quite in the
foreground
almost as big win is stopping people
going into hospital with covid19
stopping them dying in hospital from
covid19
and removing that fear that they're
going to have to run that risk and
if we can do that that's much closer
in the terms of time to the future when
we'll know those kind of answers
and we already know from the preliminary
data from astrazeneca
as in their press releases that they had
no hospital missions at all in the group
that received the vaccine so you know
those kind of things are very
encouraging
and if we can get the hospital burden
under control
then at that point and when we're
confident it's under control
we can start to think about what the
other options are
around the edges of getting this country
back to normal which we all want so much
so just kind of stay with us thanks
thank you thank you let's jump in
quickly promise just to be clear do you
expect to roll over the tier system on
february the 3rd
well we will we will judge the situation
uh
uh as as as i told the house yesterday
repeated today
uh on the on the basis of the of the
data uh but uh
i think for the time being beth you've
got to take it the tiering
is going to be a very very important
part of
our uh our campaign against coronavirus
and it's it's
i think it's very it's absolutely vital
that people continue
to stick to the guidance and and follow
the rules
that is completely crucial uh mesa
hall of the express uh thank you prime
minister um if i could ask the
medical experts first of all um as the
vaccine is rolled out and we progress
through the priority list
at what stage would you feel it be right
to lift the majority of
the restrictions is it a matter of
inoculating people in the 70s 80s
who are most at risk or would you want
to see a much
greater proportion of population uh
vaccinated
uh and prime minister um this vaccine
has been
approved in the uk faster than in eu
countries
is that because we've left the eu should
we see this is our first
brexit bonus our first big brexit bonus
and um
on subject to brexit uh the eu is saying
that there's now
less than 72 hours left to cut a deal
how confident are you that we can get a
deal in that time
so maybe on the first question i'm sure
jvc wants to come in as well
the goal of the vaccination program just
like in for coronavirus just like for
anything else
is firstly to protect vulnerable
individuals
and so the list that uh given
unfortunately coronavirus
strikes very unequally in terms of its
impact and you are at far greater risk
if you're over 80 than if you're
in your 30s and so forth that's why it's
a graduated list
of the most vulnerable people that will
help
protect them and then the second goal is
preventing people spreading it
unknowingly to others
and as jvt said we don't at this point
know whether this vaccine will have that
effect
but that's obviously one of the great
benefits that you get from
the winter flu vap jab it's the benefit
you get from the measle mumps and
rubella
jab so there is a good sort of reason
for thinking that that might be the case
but we don't
definitively know that that's the case
as we sit here today
so mesa all i would add to that is to
say that
the jcvi priority list phase one
which takes us down to people 50 years
of age
and over and obviously under the age of
under the age of 50
if you're in an at-risk group
taken together those groups it's not an
accident
that they take out with a very effective
vaccine and very high uptake
99 of covid related mortality
deaths in the uk this is not an accident
that that's how we got that's how jcvi
got
to the phase one priority listing
yeah and uh mesa just on your question
about you know how come the
the uk's uh seeming to get the the
vaccine
uh soon early uh perhaps ahead of of
uh of many other countries i think
that's that's really
down to the to the vaccine task force uh
uh more than anything else and and the
way they've gone out to
uh to organize that but you know what i
would say about this
all these vaccines all seven of the ones
that the uk is backing that these belong
these are global efforts you've got
scientists around the world coming
together
uh to make this possible and it's a
truly it's a truly international thing
and very very
uh moving to to see it on uh
brexit and uh and and where we are with
the negotiations well
uh you know we we're working we remain
uh absolutely committed to trying to
to get a deal if we if we can i think
our friends
uh know the uh what the uk
uh bottom line is and what people voted
for in uh on june the 23rd
2016 uh they voted to take back control
it's about
uh it's about making sure that the uk is
able to
uh to run its own uh
laws its own fisheries and uh and so on
and that's that's
fundamentally what it's what it's all
about and that's what we're that's what
we're all working for um let's go to
hugo guy of the eye thank you uh prime
minister
when you first announced the new tiering
system that's come into effect today
uh you suggested that it was likely to
stay in place until the end of march
given the good news on vaccines recently
is there a chance that that day could
change and that the
current covid restrictions could be
ended early and
professor von van tam can i say can i
ask this
has been a lot of attention on the
precise details
of the covid rules recently but perhaps
less attention on
uh the broader principles of how people
can protect themselves
against covid and how covid's
transmitted are you confident
that the public knows enough about the
risks of covid transmission particularly
for example issues around
ventilation which it now seems maybe
more important than
than other factors that were stressed
early in the pandemic
yeah well you go on your first question
which a lot of
uh colleagues have asked uh in one way
or the other what difference does this
make to the
to the tearing well first thing to say
is uh for now
it makes absolutely no difference
absolutely no difference we've got to
focus on
uh keeping the virus under control
getting it done
tough tiering mass community testing as
i've described
but clearly as we go on in the next uh
weeks and
and months and hopefully we're able to
use
testing and the vaccine to to drive it
down there
i suppose there will come a moment when
the as the graph of
people fed up with graphs but if you
imagine a a
the graph of uh immunized uh vaccinated
inoculated people going up
uh one way then there will come a moment
when we're able obviously
uh to start to relax the
the non-pharmaceutical interventions the
uh
all the things that that drive us you
know that are so difficult
uh we'll be able steadily uh we hope
uh to take those off just as as
community testing
uh allows what we hope will allow areas
to come down the
uh the tiering scales but we're not
there yet uh hugo and i've got to stress
that you know
this is theoretical we've got to wait
and see uh how fast we can
uh vaccinate people uh it's weeks months
of work to to go before we're in that uh
we're in that situation
uh alas but you know thank goodness uh
we now have
a vaccine to work with so
thank you hugo on the point about
ventilation i think you make a very good
point
indeed and um it's not just because i
have some
um far eastern origins i'm a great
admirer
of um the japanese system of looking for
risk
for transmission of kovid the three c's
to which i had myself d and v
uh the first seek look for closed spaces
often ones with low ventilation they are
risk areas
the second c look for situations where
there's going to be crowding
or where you can't avoid crowding the
third c
look for situations where close contact
particularly indoors
is likely to happen and then finally
on top of all that think about how long
you're going to be in those situations
d duration and then finally
on top of that think v volume how loud
and noisy is it going to be
with people shouting with raised voices
singing etc
in those kind of closed low ventilation
spaces
these are all recipes for transmission i
hope that helps
thanks very much uh hugo let's go to
harry cole lastly harry cole of the sun
thank you prime minister uh question for
professor van tam i know you can't give
us a magical number of
how many people will need to be
vaccinated before we can begin to uh
lift some measures but can you envisage
your world perhaps
in the winter a new normal where masks
and hand sanitizer just become
part of everyday life and prime minister
um i don't think i heard you give a
direct answer to mace's question there
is this a brexit bonus
have we uh have we've beaten the world
to this because we're free from brussels
um and are you concerned that 70 of your
mps
were unable to back you last night and
aren't you staring at a defeat in
february or what are you going to do to
win over
your own party on your tier system given
they're an open mutiny
um well jbt you're new
you want to go first yeah thank you
thank you prime minister
so um harry to your question um
i'll answer it in kind of three chunks
if i may
number one i don't think we're going to
eradicate
coronavirus ever i think it's going to
be
with humankind forever
secondly i think we may
get to a point where coronavirus becomes
a
seasonal problem i don't want to draw
too many parallels with flu
but possibly that is the kind of way we
would learn to live with it
and the third point is do i think there
will come a
big moment where we kind of you know
have a massive party and throw on masks
and hand sanitizer
and say that's it it's behind us like
the end of the war
no i don't i think those kind of habits
that we've learned from
that clearly stop the spread of other
respiratory viruses
such as flu will perhaps persist for
many years
and that may be a good thing if they do
um yeah so maybe a good thing or on the
other hand we may want to
get back to life as pretty much as close
to normal but you know they i mean
i i i anyway i hope i have high hopes
that the
uh that uh eventually the vaccine will
make a a very very significant
difference the way we
uh we live our we live our lives uh but
um
harry on your on your your point about
you know why we're
why we're where we're lucky enough uh to
be in the position on
on on vaccines again i'm going to uh
exercise her self denying all of my
fabled uh
diplomacy and uh intact and just say i
think that this is something that
uh you know has been we've been working
on uh the nhs has been working on for a
long time
uh the uh the vaccine task force many
people have been working on this
uh very hard for a long time i pay
tribute to to all of them and as for
um you know what might happen in uh in
future
decisions of the house of commons on um
where we should go in the in the tears i
totally understand people's
frustrations uh with the the tiering
system i
understand people uh who feel uh
frustrated because they're they feel
they're in the wrong tier
uh they've been attracted into uh
too higher tier by proximity uh to some
uh other neighborhood that uh has higher
incidence of
infection i i know how people feel about
it it's incredibly
frustrating uh what we are going to do
and i said this uh many times uh today
and
and yesterday we're gonna make sure that
we uh are as as local
and as and as uh you know sensitive as
we can possibly be
uh to local uh achievement and local
incidents of the
of the disease but don't forget the the
thing i keep saying is that you know
there is this opportunity with mass
community testing for
people to acquire agency in this and
to get a test squeeze the disease uh
kick kobit out
even before uh the vaccine comes so so
harry i'd like to come back because
i do like to be um challenged when i
have perhaps not made myself clear and
the prime minister has picked me up on
this occasion and it's quite alright and
publicly
don't know but it's quite all right
because it gives me a chance to clarify
what i mean here
i do not think the government will
continue
to have to recommend social distancing
masks and hand sanitizer
forever and a day i hope we will get
back to a much more normal world
but the point i was trying to make was
do i think
possibly some of those personal habits
for some people will persist
longer and perhaps become enduring for
some people
yes i think that's possible as it as in
as in the far east yes yeah no well who
knows who knows
um thank you very much everybody that's
uh that uh concludes the
session thanks harry
there we are that's the prime minister
confirming that uh
vaccine the vaccine will start being
rolled out
next week he said though that it would
be some months before
all the most vulnerable are protected he
said we mustn't get carried away with
optimism
there are immense logistical challenges
ahead simon stephens head of the nhs
said the rollout would begin at 50 nhs
hospital hubs he called
them next week but but he said the bulk
of the vaccine program
will be between january and then march
and april between january
and march and april for the the
vulnerable the most vulnerable he said
and then jonathan van tam he said he got
emotional when he heard the scientists
set out why they are convinced that this
vaccine is
safe um there were lots of train
analogies
and trains arriving and so forth but he
said everyone should be very excited but
then he said
but if you relax too soon all you'll do
is create a tidal wave of infection
and then on the issue of whether to take
or have the vaccine he said
people need to take it um it won't help
you
if people don't take it so there we are
let's talk to our
political editor uh beth rigby and uh
beth so i mean they had good news to
report
at last but tempered also with caution
wasn't it
yeah absolutely mark a real really two
sides of the coin there wasn't it in the
sense of
the genuine happiness and you heard
jonathan van tan talk about it there
about
this breakthrough in a vaccine actually
being approved the first one
approved in the world by the uk
regulator
and it will be rolled out next week and
simon stephens there detailing
how it was going to be rolled out first
in hospitals in patients coming in
from care homes so outpatients coming in
from care homes
could get the vaccine and then gradually
roll down to a thousand hubs across
england and then potentially into care
homes if they can sort out the
transportation issues
and then eventually to pharmacists and
there we go
tangible uh real developments in rolling
out that vaccine and very exciting it is
too but then on the other side
of that coin what did the vaccine
actually mean in terms of how in the
longer term
it will affect our lives how many people
need to be vaccinated
jonathan van tan saying didn't know if
it could stop transmission
and then at the end uh talking about
when harry cole asked him about would we
live in a world without coronavirus um
he said i don't think we'll ever live in
a world without coronavirus but we could
get to the point
where it's like seasonal flu so it's a
seasonal
virus rather than something that
dominates our lives
and forces us to all be apart from each
other with hand sanitizer on and wearing
masks so uh two sides there in terms of
where we go with the vaccine and how
free we are going to be
when i think that it was more negative
on that side
the prime minister i asked him about the
tearing system asked him whether
the rollout of the vaccine meant that we
could perhaps
look forward to restrictions being eased
earlier
and he was very much of the view that
we're going to be living
with this cheering for some time uh
asked about whether he would roll over
uh the tyrion on february the third he
didn't really want to get into that
because that's a political hot potato
that he doesn't really want to has to
grasp today but he had 55 mps
on his own benches voting against the
tier systems
now that tells you all you need to know
about the likelihood
of a bigger rebellion even in february
so brilliant news on the vaccine but
in terms of where we are now caution
about the roll out caution about how
quickly our lives can go
back to normal and questions too about
whether or not we'll live with permanent
changes
not just beyond the spring but for the
rest of our lives
beth thanks very much indeed we'll leave
it there because i just want to go
uh quickly to professor biata campman
who is the director of the vaccine
center